What if the sun disappeared right now?
Would you be able to handle eternal
darkness, cold temperatures?
How about flying off into space?
The son is the only star in our solar
system and it gives life to everything
here on earth.
Would we even be alive if it vanished?
This is what if, and here's what
would happen if the sun disappeared.
The truth is we wouldn't even notice
for the first eight and a half minutes.
This is how long it takes
sunlight to travel to our planet.
So even if the sun disappeared,
it's last ray of light would take
510 seconds to reach your skin.
And what about gravity?
The Sun is the dominant gravitational
force in our solar system.
It has all eight planets moving around it.
So if the sun disappeared,
would we fly off into space?
Yes, but not right away.
The force of gravity turns
out to have speed to it.
His theory of general relativity,
Einstein proved that gravity is just as
fast as light and not instantaneous as
was previously thought.
This means the earth would still be
orbiting a recently vanished star with no
clue of the upcoming darkness,
but just for eight and a half minutes.
When the last of the sun's
rays reached the earth.
Eternal night wouldn't
be our only problem.
The very same moment the sun
disappeared from the sky.
Earth would start traveling into
space at 18 miles per second.
Assuming the earth didn't collide with
any other planets or asteroids or get
sucked into a black hole,
it would be moving in a straight line
for 43,000 years before it found another
start orbit, but you wouldn't have to
worry about that within two seconds.
The moon would go dark since there
would be no sunlight to reflect,
but the stars would still shine and
your electricity would still work unless
it's powered by solar panels.
However,
gravity and illumination aren't the
only things we rely on the sun for.
Plants need the sun for photosynthesis.
Turning light into energy is how
plants stay alive. Without sunlight,
most small plants would
be dead within days.
Larger ones like trees would survive
for several decades due to their slow
metabolism. This would knock out
the bottom tier of the food chain.
Most animals would die off slowly.
Only scavengers feeding on the dead
would remain until they froze to death
because within a week,
the average temperature on earth would
drop to a own chilling 32 degrees
Fahrenheit,
and by the end of the first year,
minus 150 degrees would be the new
norm and it would keep dropping until
stabilizing at minus
400 degrees Fahrenheit.
The oceans would grow colder too,
but just on the surface,
thanks to geo thermal vents,
they would remain liquid
underneath despite being
buried under a thick layer of
ice. So if you're lucky enough to survive,
consider moving to the ocean floor.
In the end,
the organisms living around those geo
thermal vents would be the only living
beings not to notice any difference.
They don't need the sun to live and
could continue to thrive for billions of
years until the planet became a frozen
chunk of rock drifting and space.